three-two-one right sorry I cut you off
so many times so like I deserve it do it
do it to me this entire time in virtual
versus real life news submitted by lost
my keys
Oh mm-hmm and if sometimes it's in my
pocket I know or my hand a new study
says video games socially affect girls
more than boys you know why cuz we get
pissed off at the boys for [ __ ]
playing them well how do they social e
[ __ ] up the ladies because I get
annoying because the ladies are too dumb
to know it's fake mmm so the reason why
is because it's particularly
ten-year-old girls who play more games
they had less social competence at 12
because there's less girls playing game
so for boys it's just another boy it's
just another play time so they can go
with other boys and then still have
social interaction and still plays still
the same social interactions just online
now or whatever yeah there's not a lot
of other girls that also play so that
affects them with their social
competence what are they better with
socializing with boys now because
they'll be like yeah they'll be like hey
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] nut [ __ ] your mom
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you know how like guys
got to do that so then these
ten-year-old girls get really good at
[ __ ] talking and know how to roast boys
or something reminds me of like the Tom
the tomboy that would play like
basketball with the boys yeah so they
don't make a clear distinction like that
they're just saying that overall girls
that are 10 years old specifically who
play more games they were less social
puppeted so by the time that they were
told so they're saying that there's a
study here from Norway that investigated
all these questions between boys and
girls and like time spent gaming and
social competence and a group of 873
kids starting at the age of six and then
they would check in every two years
until the age of 12 so it showed that
more game
didn't generally predict worst social
outcomes for boys but a difficult would
you rather your girl be a [ __ ] you know
like what's worse like okay like no I'm
not saying like that extreme but it's
like you know what I mean like jus like
what do you want for your kids like do
you want to be good at video games and
socializing maybe she gets into coding
or programming or something or do and
like those people aren't good social
activity is nothing but they're killing
it at whatever they're doing and it's
also a siren and it's also like a
balance thing too like if they're just
playing video games I'm like okay I can
see why because maybe like you were
saying like the tomboy are you were
saying the tomboy of the group they are
gonna be completely different you know
in the in the guys circle but then the
other girls are gonna be like oh that
girl is [ __ ] weird don't like let her
come around us so she's always gonna be
isolated in that way girls are [ __ ]
me you can always put her in like
different like she could be dad seeing
or she can going art or she should play
a different sport with all girls and
stuff there's also always like four
brothers that really know her way around
dudes yeah and I think just the same if
the girls had three other sisters she
might not even lose competencies yeah
they play video games I was gonna say
I'm wondering if it was maybe like the
I'm not sure if it's the video game is
causing the incompetency like what if
these people are just predisposed to
like not maybe interacting socially as
well and then because of that they like
playing video games so I'm wondering if
that's maybe but then that's also like a
form of helping them though yeah they're
they're finding an outlet over that you
know so it's like but it's more
prevalent in females than males so that
I guess it's trying to point out that
it's negatively affecting girls because
he can't relate to the girls maybe but
like what if your kid really sucked at
dance and you like put her in dance it's
really you mean just to be like it
sounds like wow would you react to the
parent like okay we're gonna you know
you go see the best dance and you could
be in your life like this is not my
child you like you don't want to claim
them but in your halves I wouldn't care
I don't think it might be really good
exercise to put your kid in something
that you know they're gonna suck at just
to like teach them everything just to
[ __ ] deal with my mom did that with
us where
we should put you in that you suck that
well I mean I was good at everything but
no I'm just kidding but she purposely
[ __ ] Assad out things that made you
fail no no no she didn't do that but so
I guess I used that example because I
saw that happy with my little sister so
she would my mom would put us in
different things that we showed some
sort of interest in and then if we suck
she wouldn't just like pull this out she
was just like okay well keep going yeah
but then if we really really sucked in
and one of us like if we were like we
really hate this we don't want to do it
and she would pull this out oh that's
nice
this forces you to be like a little bit
uncomfortable and like deal with
whatever you know issue that is and not
like just like not give up cuz you're
not good at it I'm gonna start with ya I
did beauty pageants with your haircut oh
thank you no I did and I didn't win and
I got first runner-up out of two people
I was one of the two yeah I look like a
boy it looks like a little boy and I
never won any of them but I saw Miss
Congeniality and I was like I can do
this that's time it's like ready for it
my parents I think that was an example
of what you were - what you're saying
you know I shouldn't have done it but
you have a hit a kid so have you done
I'm like poking you I wanted to poke her
just make sure she's still here um have
you ever done that to your son to push
him in things that he's not good at um
not necessarily I mean he so he's been
in baseball basketball and then he's
doing piano right now and he's done
swimming and these are all activities
that he was interested in first right so
I didn't really push anything on in the
heat didn't really want or that I
thought that he wasn't gonna be good at
not that he was really good at the
sports stuff he's got swimming wasn't it
swimming yes so like the other ones like
the contact force stuff like the
basketball and the baseball it wasn't
his thing it was also just for for the
baseball one it was really young and he
has been interested in doing football
because his friends are doing football
hmm so I'm like cool well sign you up to
that but just that we missed the sign up
right I'd line for this year so maybe
next year we're gonna have him do it but
if I have a kid all the activities that
he chooses to do or she chooses you or
gonna be indoors because I don't want to
deal with like the sunlight about the
bleachers yeah I'm not doing that
I just like all Android yeah we do they
really could be like the lady with
umbrella yeah okay I get the racetrack
you know looking at everyone like
peasants oh gosh I'm just allergic to
the Sun we don't get along you know we
don't like each other
good times I do yeah I have all these
problems so like I yeah it's not good
yeah yeah the Sun [ __ ] you up it bucks
you up it's not cute like how much Sun
can you have like it it can call right
now or no this is actually the first
time and like a little bit where I've
been like woo it makes me like a little
dizzy and stuff yeah it's weird it's
really weird yeah I [ __ ] love this
song yeah I know so when people ask me
on dates and ask me to go the beach and
[ __ ] I'm like no
for many reasons no well have a glass of
wine and look at it you know I think we
went to Hawaii too much with my
girlfriend and then now she's sometimes
gets like benign little cancer things
yes oh that's scary because I mean I
think similar skin with you yeah I
didn't know that I didn't know I thought
I thought everyone could ten I thought
like if you just stood in the Sun long
enough favored one content I didn't know
that that was something that was like a
redhead trade or whatever i doubt i was
learning some stuff didn't you play
tennis in high school no she did oh oh
you know what it is she lived in the
beach she lived in a beach town that's
an outdoor sport and she had a lot of
sun and i think what it is assured he's
already predisposed her skin type is
predisposed to to skin cancer and things
like that so the exposure early onset
exposure and all that probably early in
life and everything plus lifestyle sped
up the process I can see that happening
hundred percent 100% so what happens
within this article what's the end of it
so they're just saying like hey you know
according to the study be mindful of
girls that they might have some less
social competition I think a lot of
people just today not even just girls -
yeah yeah but it is important to note
that this Norwegian study was completed
four years ago which is a really long
time and tech time the things you've
also fashion so that's something to
consider because they didn't include the
fact like the difference they did not
differentiate between the genre of game
or even look into watching shows about
gaming like YouTube videos yeah other
people gaming they didn't consider that
either
so again [ __ ] and Guddi what about
four years ago it's not even around four
years ago I don't think so maybe yeah I
think so yeah I think it just came out I
know is that like like dating apps like
speaking technology [ __ ] [ __ ] I
got married like when tinder was like on
the come-up and now there's so many of
them I feel like that's changed the way
everyone communicates yeah the really
specific to like you can find one for
anybody I mean yeah it's only farmers or
whatever there's a lot of lonely you're
joking
yeah there's that bad about that and I
have to google it cuz I was in Texas and
someone mentioned it and they started
laughing about it like farmers only
document I saw one word it was too like
couple there was a couple with tinfoil
hats it was like a conspiracy of all the
commercials I'm like this is real yeah
there's like gay Mormons or like what's
annoying is when you're on a regular ass
one and then you get some creepy yes
[ __ ] and the messages that's like I had
someone asked me yesterday I have a
girlfriend we're on riot together but
that's not what he presented I was like
wait a minute
I liked your profile but now you're like
the oh my gosh I was like no I don't
want to be in a threesome with you thank
you for the offer I really appreciate
that I'm looking for love not that I
like don't want to be a side [ __ ] it's
really annoying but that's why I think
the culture now and like no one like
knows how to interact with you you know
what I mean
from what I hear like did your cousin
mentioned before like now the new thing
is you [ __ ] first and then you get to
know each other that's pretty much what
everyone expects I'm like no what do you
have you probably don't even know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]